Japan prepares to say goodbye to its
longest-serving prime minister Shinzo
Abe with a lavish send-off that's the
source of growing controversy
instead of mourning many have been
protesting with much of their anger
directed at the current prime minister
fumio kashida
clearly showed his stance of continuing
Albus policies and he's forcing it on
the nation
coming from a political Dynasty it
seemed natural at first that such a
distinguished life should be celebrated
with a state funeral
but the problems began soon after his
assassination at a political rally in
July when it emerged the suspect bore a
grudge against Abe for his links to the
unification Church which the man blamed
for making his mother bankrupt widely
known as the Moonies and associated with
organizing Mass weddings the unification
church has long been regarded by some as
a dangerous cult that pressures its
followers into making exorbitant
donations it was founded in South Korea
in the 1950s but has been expanding its
influence here in Japan for decades
this was Abe giving a recorded address
to a big Gathering of the church a year
ago it was then revealed the
organization had other links with
Japan's ruling party the members of my
cabinet have pledged to examine their
own relationship with the organization
and cuts all ties with it
that in turn has led to charges of
persecution by the church which claims
three million members this was a protest
rally held in Seoul
stop human rights repression stop
Distortion reporting religious
repression the roiling controversy is
far from the kind of respectful and
reflective atmosphere Japan's embattled
prime minister had hoped for the state
funeral and we've seen kishida plummet
in the polls I mean he's dropped 20
points you know and you know his
negatives now exceed his positives about
two to one people are against it Shinzo
Abe an extremely influential but
divisive figure in life so proving it
seems in-depth Rob McBride Al Jazeera
Tokyo